Okay, I'm Bengi.
If you need any
other sizes,
you please let me
know, all right ?
Okay.
There you go.
Thank you.
What's your name ?
Taffeta.
Okay.
Oh, this is a yes.
Yes.
Yeah.
Thanks for coming.
Hi, how are you ?
Did someone help
you today ?
Yeah, um...
Hmm.
Who was it ?
You know, I
don't--I don't see him.
Do you know what
he looks like ?
Yeah, he is wearing
like a-- like a vest,
or like a plaid shirt,
I feel like--
I don't know what everyone
who works here wore today.
Um, he had short hair,
so that'll probably do it.
Just that.
He's...
Black eye--black eyes ?
He has black eyes ?
Yeah, he had black eyes.
So he has black pupils ?
Yeah.
Are there any other
distinguishing features ?
I would guess he probably
voted for Obama.
I know I did.
What ?
Oh my God, that's him,
that's definitely him.
He doesn't work here.
Okay.
You know what
I just remembered ?
Nobody helped me.
So forget it.
Okay, we work on commission
here, so if someone
did help you,
you should probably tell me.
Can I just, like,
give you,
like $10 and you
just leave me alone ?
Darren, Bengi, Debri,
Kaching, get in here, please.
Kaching ?
Thank you.
That's him.
You really can't
tell us apart ?
Whatever, Taffeta.
Your name says Amy
on your card.
Yeah.
It would, I was
in the witness--
I witnessed, uh...
You were in the
witness ?
Protection program ?
Protection--
Program.
And you just told
me that ?
Hey.
Hi.
Did someone help
you today ?
Yeah, the Asian
over there.